I adore Picard season three I'm actually
excited about Thursdays again when this
Picard's new episode drops I love it
but
there seems to be quite a few silly
mistakes in the series and they're
getting a little irritated but one in
particular has got me quite irritated
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
thank you
so in every episode of Star Trek Picard
season three there seems to be one
slight irritating error and it seems to
be one in every single episode in the
first episode there's this clue that
Beverly Crusher sent to Picard a clue
that he didn't know about and the only
will Rika knew about and she told him
don't tell anyone but he went running
immediately to will something that
happened while he was incapacitated and
while he was looking to support it stuck
out like a sore thumb it was a bit of an
odd thing it was an error a couple of
episodes ago Beverly Crusher talked
about the new changes how they have
internal organs Etc and that this was
Evolution well it clearly isn't
Evolution because that's not what
evolution is evolution is a natural
progression this was obviously quite
clearly not natural so why she used that
word I just don't know
there's the whole thing with the Titan a
that's quite annoying is it a new ship
is it an old ship is it a refit ship
when you refit a existing Starship what
you do is you upgrade the technology you
take a ship that's 20 30 years old and
you put new technology aboard it what
you don't do is completely rebuild the
Starships it looks completely different
but leave 20 year oldness sells on board
it it makes no sense it's very confusing
and to be honest the writers seem to got
confused because occasionally they call
the Titan a new ship and occasionally
they call it a refit and it's just a
little bit confusing
but none of these mistakes are really a
concern they're mild irritations at best
however the last episode this a very
exciting double episode that we've been
really looking forward to that
terminalis is called the TNG movie we
never got to see
there is one big problem brewing and I
can't really Let It Go but what is this
problem so apparently on this Frontier
day the entire star Fleet all of them
are going to be in one place
all of them
now if you're a bit of a Trekkie you
might know where I'm going with this in
the last episode Geordie has said that
he is now sick of telling Federation
command that how bad an idea this is I
mean just from a strategic military
point of view it's a terrible idea you
have all of your military Assets in one
place at one time
no military on Earth would do that it's
stupid why is the forge the only one
that's actually sticking his hand up on
going
but that that's idiotic why isn't Picard
going that that that's the stupidest
thing I've ever heard instead he's going
I've got to go to this bloody speech
this stupid Federation
instead of going whoa whoa
whoa what the hell is going on here
now another thing is because I I don't I
do find it a little Annoying that
they've come up with this Frontier day
we've already got Federation day which
is supposedly the day when the
Federation was formed when you know like
the the first treaties reside we've
always got first Contact Day really
critical velocity
yeah
when the Vulcans first landed on Earth
and zephron Cochrane did his first
warped flight
now we also have this Frontier day now
this is the day apparently that the
Starfleet began it is the date time
matalis says it's actually the date of
the launch of the nx01 Enterprise and
that's the 5th of April
so they've created a new day for this
show whatever
um 250th anniversary got great
what
I'm a little bit confused by this
because
all of the starfleets vessels however
idiotic putting them all in one place is
there's also some quite big reasons why
it's just not even remotely possible the
main one being the Federation is huge
now Picard himself in 2373 said actually
that the Federation is over 8 000 light
years across now let's assume the Earth
is in right in the middle of the
Federation which it isn't but let's
assume it is and that no vessel is
actually operating outside of federation
space let's assume those two things so
no vessel in theory is more than 4 000
light years from this event
so how long would it take a Starship at
maximum warp to do four thousand light
years well we don't actually know that
exactly because Star Trek is a little
fuzzy when it comes to the math they
change it occasionally but we do have
some in-cannon Clues so for one
during the episode where no one has gone
before data talks about how they are 2.7
million light years away from Federation
space and he says it will take
approximately 300 years at maximum warp
to get back to Federation
now that equates roughly to 9 000 light
years a year so at maximum warp which a
Starship can't actually do for long
periods of time would take six months
so you need to have this planned at
least six months in advance and you
would need to start removing your
vessels from the outer parts of the
Federation at least six months before
this event
but
at warp 6.3 it's calculated it actually
would take nine years to cross the
Federation so you're at least four and a
half years away if the best you can do
is whop 6.3 now that is really sort of
cruising speed one of the things that
was so impressive about the Intrepid
class was that it can actually cruise at
what nine point or whatever it was which
is actually very unusual the Enterprise
used to fly around at all five or six
all the time and we know that they could
not do maximum warp for long periods we
know this from their encounters with the
Borg we know this is encounters with q
that when the Enterprise D and I know
that was an older vessel but when the
internet's D was trying to escape
anything and they tried to do maximum
more breathe and break that
they couldn't do it for long periods now
the other thing you have to remember is
that lots of the Federation starships
are actually older models they're not
all Sovereign class they're not all
newer vessels there's a lot of older
ships out there or refit ships like the
Titan so they have all the technology
the Titan for example has the cells walk
the cells that are 20 years old
so you can assume it probably can't hold
maximum warp for any longer than the
Enterprise D could
so
it's just so basically what I'm saying
is the Federation would not just be
defenseless for a couple of weeks say
Well they're doing this Frontier day it
could be defenseless on the outer edges
for anything up to a year
six months there six months back and
surely the outer edges of the Federation
is kind of where you need your defenses
you know like on the Romulan border and
things like that so it doesn't again
make any logical sense that they would
be able to do this thing of bringing all
the Starships back to one point even if
they were stupid enough to want to
so now I know they've done this because
the there's going to be a big threat the
changelings and whoever the changelings
bosses is planning an attack on Frontier
day and they're planning it looks like
to try to take out the entire fleet in
one foul swoop
but for that to be a storyline it really
is through storyline that makes sense
because this is science fiction and they
seem to have forgotten that us trekkies
actually like
do this kind of thing we actually like
doing the math we actually like thinking
about the practicalities of what they're
talking about we don't just go oh okay
they've done that
we actually do get slightly irritated
when they do stupid things like this I
love the movie First Contact but it
always frustrated me that the um
Enterprise E was able to get from the
neutral zone back to Earth in seemed
like minutes set of course for Earth hi
sir
maximum warp two seconds later sir
there's another Starship coming in
it's the Enterprise
[Music]
the battle started the Federation were
not doing very well Captain Picard
decides right we're going in and he's
there while the battle is still going on
it literally seems to have taken minutes
that was necessary for the storyline but
it always stuck in my throat I never
liked it it always irritated me
they're going to do it again in Picard
season three now is this a big problem
is this something we should really get
annoyed about
no
compared to some of the mistakes in
season one and two of Picard this is
nothing this is just um okay they've
changed the rules to fit the storyline
which is necessary the writers have been
a little bit lazy gonna say and they've
just fit storyline that fits
so what they do that all the time in
Star Trek as I said they didn't first
Contact they did lots and lots of other
Star Treks they fuzz the numbers
occasionally if Tony metallis does want
to move forward and does want to do
another series of Star Trek I would like
him to be a little bit more careful with
the detail I'd like a few little less
mistakes Thanos trekkies have to run
around to try to figure out reasons to
make it make sense
they shouldn't do these mistakes the
hollow deck shouldn't have its own power
source while the rest of the ship is
about to run out of air
it doesn't make sense it's not logical
stop putting these things in there just
for the sake of being able to
let's make Star Trek make sense the
Vulcans would seriously lose their minds
at some of the storylines being put in
in series three never mind seasons one
and two but guys get into the comments
tell me what you think does this make
sense or is this one step too far now I
know the changelings have probably
ordered the entire fleet and this has
all been set up over a long period but
let's be honest not everybody is a
changeling and surely somebody should
have pointed out that this is stupid or
have I completely forgotten something
that is actually really important get
into the comments and tell me exactly
what you're thinking if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification really helps us
out and as always if you want to support
the channel even further you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where you get most of our videos before
everybody on YouTube and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you get it without
having to watch the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]